just before dawn this morning the FBI
raided the Florida home of longtime
Trump adviser Roger stone will be
joining us in a minute the CNN producer
stood across the street recording it all
with the camera as dozens of heavily
armed agents piled out of vehicles and
swarm stone's house some carried
high-powered rifles with extra magazines
hanging from military web gear others
were helmets body armor and tactical
gloves at least one agent carried two
separate rifles in addition to his
sidearm the man in front of him appeared
to have a flashbang grenade on his belt
the whole team scrambled over stones
lawn and pounded on the door stone
appeared he was barefoot and wearing a
t-shirt the agent slapped him in
handcuffs before they let him away to
jail Stone told the agents that his wife
was upstairs with their dogs Stone's
wife is deaf and didn't understand what
was happening stone was worried that one
of the men in tactical gear might shoot
her by accident tragedies like that
regularly occurred during law
enforcement raids and that's why federal
agents don't raid the homes of people
like Roger stone there's no need to
stone has no history of violence he
doesn't run an international drug cartel
he hasn't been charged with murder or
even was spying for Vladimir Putin Roger
stone is accused of lying during the
course of the Russia investigation under
normal circumstances during normal times
prosecutors would just call his lawyer
and arrange a surrender stone is 66
years old he's so broke from Mullen
related legal expenses that he can't
afford health insurance he is hardly a
flight risk but no that's not what they
did instead the feds went with automatic
weapons and a cameraman from CNN you
don't need to be a Roger stone partisan
a fan to see that there is something
wrong with what happened this morning
the most powerful person in America is
now an unelected prosecutor with no
functional oversight over what he does
Robert Muller commands in effect his own
domestic army you just saw them he can
use it however he likes and he does well
their crushes people when it's not even
necessary to do it weak people mostly
and he does it in ways that are clearly
designed to send a political message
that is not how democracies are supposed
to work and you'd think our media would
be bothered by this
Porter's are not supposed to side with
prosecutors who abuse their power or
anyone else who abuses power they are
supposed to hold the powerful to account
that's why they exist but not anymore
now they're all in the same team robert
muller is a hero to our press corps when
his agents raid the home of an elderly
man charged with piddling crimes they
air the tape and they celebrate Roger
stone life Donald Trump is a political
con man who's showman stick has finally
caught up with him let me be the first
to say if you look up the word scumbag
in the dictionary you're going to see
Roger stones picture there I am just so
damn happy this guy is indited in Iraq
he is a bully
[Applause]
I'd like to have her in charge of your
life so damn happy so a barefoot Roger
stone is taken to jail if that thrills
you it may be time to take a break
pause and reassess what's happened to
your soul but no one reassessed today
they were joist one famous neocon summed
up his feelings this way quote given his
proclivities maybe Roger stone would
enjoy prison ha get it stone may get
raped behind bars how awesome is that so
how should the rest of us people who
aren't spending our lives on Twitter
feel about what happened this morning is
America's safer well not if you believed
in the Russia collusion story we still
haven't caught those villains assuming
they exist indeed two years in there are
still no evidence at all that any
American committed an actual crime
during the 2016 election Roger stone for
example stands accused of misdeeds
committed long after the votes were
counted his alleged crimes arose from an
investigation into other crimes we have
not yet found the charges against stone
include obstruction of proceedings
witness tampering five counts of lying
to Congress the core of it of the
charges is that stone mischaracterized
his conversations with the left ring
talk radio host called Randy credit
co-credit Co prosecutors say served as
an intermediary with Julian Assange who
runs WikiLeaks now none of what stone or
credit code did in their conversations
with Assange is illegal journals do the
kind of thing all the time it's the
lying we are told that must be punished
with a jail time okay but again and
we've noted this before what you're
looking at here is a brand new standard
of conduct one that nobody who's been
paying close attention to this country
for the last twenty years would even
recognize there's an awful lot of lying
out there an awful lot a lot of it's not
even acknowledged as long every time an
illegal immigrant lies to a federal
immigration officer that is a felony
every time a politician lies under oath
in the Congress that's a potential jail
term both of those happen a lot but
nobody has ever charged for any of it
now this is hardly a defense of lying
lying is bad it's corrosive it's one of
the main problems with our political
system
actually everybody lies all the time but
there is at least one thing that is
worse than lying even lying under oath
and it's the Selective application of
federal law one standard for the
powerful and well-connected former
attorney generals for example another
standard for barefoot 66 year old men
with unfashionable political views some
people skate others are destroyed it all
depends on who you know that's what
America is becoming and we ought to
fight that